hey guys I'm just McDonald it is January
the 7th and you're tuned into gamespot
news let's talk about some stuff first
off there's an alien game on the horizon
which has been doing the room around for
a while but Sega has confirmed that
alien isolation will be indeed happening
Creative Assembly will be taking the
lead for the game centered around Ellen
Ripley's daughter Amanda in terms of
what we know about the plot and gameplay
Amanda will find herself in a remote
station with a xenomorph but Creative
Assembly has promised the game won't set
you up with an assault rifle and throw
Ward's of aliens at you it's all set to
hit ps4 ps3 xbox one xbox 360 and PC in
late 2014 is this the kind of alien game
you'd want to play let me know in the
comments Sony's had a pretty busy day
today including finally delivering on
all those Gaikai acquisition and clubs
dreaming rumors that they've been
sitting on for months the grand result
as announced by Andrew house today is
PlayStation now a service that will
stream PS 1 2 and 3 titles across
various devices that include your ps4
and Vita as well as mobile devices and
most of Sony's bravia tvs from the 2014
range there hasn't been much information
as to exactly which titles will be
available at launch and so far Sony have
only demoed the feature with the last of
us and beyond two souls the services set
to launch in summer 2014 and in terms of
price Sony insinuated that customers
will be able to rent titles on an
individual basis or as a part of a
subscription package presumably separate
from PlayStation Plus what sort of
pricing on an individual or subscription
basis would you like to see from the
service you can let me narrow down below
last up anyone expecting so need to be
quiet about the ps4 sales figures after
Microsoft's announcement of Xbox once
yesterday would have been sorely
mistaken the PlayStation giant took to
CES to announce that 4.2 million ps4
units have been sold worldwide as of
December 28 which is quite a bit more
than the three
Xbox one unit sold for a similar period
that microsoft announced yesterday do
you see this having an impact on the
ultimate success of the xbox one or do
you think there's more than enough room
for both consoles like I do you can let
me know in the comments down below or on
my Twitter where I'm at Jess McDonald if
you're looking to get all caught up on
the exciting announcements and dramatic
Michael Bay breakdowns of CES 2014 then
make sure you stop by our show page on
gamespot that's all I've got for you
today but do check back with me again
tomorrow where there's a very good
chance I'll have a second more news I'll
be again then